Ever since we heard that unmistakable laughter
at the end of the trailer for Star Wars Episode
IX: The Rise of Skywalker...
“Ha.”
… we've been stunned that Emperor Palpatine
is returning for the conclusion of the Skywalker
Saga.
More than a few fans, however, are less stunned
than peeved.
They want to know why on Earth director J.J.
Abrams and co-writer Chris Terrio would bring
back a Big Bad who has supposedly been dead
for more than 30 years.
Could they simply not think of any other way
to raise the stakes of the sequel's story?
What kind of narrative gymnastics will Rise
of Skywalker have to engage in to make this
plot development make sense?
How, exactly, can this even happen?
Palpatine is a central figure in both the
original and prequel trilogies.
He starts as a Sith Lord in disguise serving
as a senator in the Galactic Republic, where
he engineers the rise of the Empire.
He successfully turns Anakin Skywalker to
the Dark Side of the Force and nearly achieves
complete dominance over the galaxy.
It's ultimately his rage at his inability
to turn Anakin's son Luke to the Dark Side
that's his undoing.
At the conclusion of Star Wars Episode VI:
Return of the Jedi, Palpatine attempts to
manipulate Luke into killing his father, Anakin,
a.k.a. Darth Vader.
But the plan fails.
When Luke refuses to fight, Palpatine attempts
to simply kill the young Jedi, assaulting
him with Force lightning as Vader watches.
But Vader turns away from the Dark Side and
toward redemption.
He seizes the Emperor and tosses him down
a seemingly bottomless shaft, mortally wounding
himself in the process.
He seemingly kills Palpatine and brings balance
to the Force.
The sequel trilogy picks up 30 years after
these events, as the remnants of the Empire
are reforming into the nefarious First Order
under the guidance of the Supreme Leader Snoke
and his protege, Kylo Ren.
Ren is Ben Skywalker, son of Han Solo and
General Leia, and a former apprentice of Luke's.
Star Wars Episode VII: The Force Awakens clearly
seems to set up Snoke as the Big Bad of the
sequel trilogy, but midway through Star Wars
Episode VIII: The Last Jedi, Kylo Ren kills
Snoke, leaving the trilogy without a top bad
guy.
"It's time to let old things die."
Snoke's death was puzzling for many fans,
and was a major factor in the backlash that
The Last Jedi endured from some Star Wars
fans.
The tease of Palpatine's return to the franchise
stoked the ire of these fans even further,
as the move is easy to interpret as an attempt
by Abrams and company to cash in on nostalgia
for the original series.
After all, Palpatine has not been featured
in the sequel series up to this point, and
resurrecting him could be seen as lazy writing.
His return raises so many questions: does
it lessen Darth Vader's heroic sacrifice?
Are we supposed to now buy that Palpatine
has been pulling strings for all of the intervening
years between the original and sequel trilogies,
and nobody has caught on?
Did he actually die and return somehow, or
did he actually survive getting the heave-ho
down a bottomless shaft?
The degree to which one is willing to go along
with this plot wrinkle is going to depend
largely on trust in Abrams.
In a recent interview with Empire magazine,
the director made it known that he's aware
that some fans are confused, and he attempted
to reassure those fans that he knows what
he's doing.
He said:
"Some people feel like we shouldn't revisit
the idea of Palpatine, and I completely understand
that.
But if you're looking at these nine films
as one story, I don't know many books where
the last few chapters have nothing to do with
those that have come before.
If you look at the first eight films, all
the set-ups of what we're doing in [Rise of
Skywalker] are there in plain view."
One thing we know is that Palpatine's appearance
will be no mere cameo; he's going to be instrumental
to the events of Episode IX, and if a recent
leak detailing his involvement in the narrative
turns out to be accurate, his return could
actually end up making a great deal more sense
than it might initially seem to.
“Ha,”
We'll find out the reasoning behind Palpatine's
return and surely find out how fans feel about
it when Star Wars Episode IX: The Rise of
Skywalker hits the big screen December 20.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.